hi I'm Erik Bosse and we hear new
rockstars talk a lot about what we love
about sabirah movies but some of the
most memorable superhero movie moments
were the ones that made us totally
cringe so we asked all of you guys what
your top cringe superhero movie moments
were and the results are in starting
with number 15 Bane's awkward
conversation with the CIA agent in the
Dark Knight Rises and even though I
mostly like Tom Hardy's Bane as a
villain
I will admit his voice is a little goofy
or equal to du Loup edition of Peter and
it definitely took some getting used to
during that opening airplane sequence
with the CIA agents played by
Littlefinger I pull that off will you
die it would be extremely painful you're
a big guy for you so this exchange has
become kind of an obscure meme in some
niche corners of the internet basically
when you take your lives out of context
they're kind of a subtle sexual
connotation George now I'm going to
quickly thank war robots for sponsoring
this video we're robots is a mobile app
multiplayer game where you play as these
awesome looking robots that fight each
other in the near future it's not just a
game I'm you from the future where were
robots is real my name is commander
cupcakes Oh as a game war robot says
pretty cool check it out you get teamed
up in a group of six to fight another
group of six with random players coming
fifty million people all over the world
try to capture these beacons and destroy
each other there's a variety of
abilities and location and when I play
it on my phone it's just so much fun and
the graphics look amazingly vivid you
think that looks legit wait till you're
on a post-apocalyptic hellscape holding
lieutenant Twinkie after his robotic
exoskeleton was slow to fit by in a
spiral yeah yeah yeah cool just click on
the link below in the description and
you'll receive an exclusive bonus for
new rockstars fans 100 gold 100,000
silver and two Punisher firearms just
don't give them more weapons the
destruction and humanity okay don't look
that much older than me
what year in the future are you from
year 2019 20 months from now it's gonna
be a crazy couple years
commander cupcake ow that was a lot of
blood on the shirt anyway we're robots
get on it back to the video okay moving
on to number 14
another debatable mention that might
make you mad at me also it's another
kind of sexy moment involving a big guy
Black Widows weird palm stroke [ __ ]
palm stroke to Hulk and Avengers age of
Ultron
now I also really enjoyed age of Ultron
but like The Dark Knight Rises it's a
sequel that struggled to live up to its
nearly perfect predecessor and one thing
I kind of struggled with in the movie
was the random romantic subplot between
Black Widow and Hulk like it just kind
of comes out of nowhere and it all
starts in this opening battle with Black
Widow somehow knowing how to tame Hulk I
running her hand across his palm I've no
idea how they ever could have practiced
this without Black Widow just getting
like low-keyed around I guess at the
time I just figured this meant Black
Widow is somehow a Hulk whisperer next
up on our countdown number 13 Superman
Returns and proves that he feels nothing
so Bryan Singer's version of Superman in
2006 elevated the character into a god
figure also kind of an action figure
Brandon Ralph looked like a young
Christopher Reeve but he lacked some of
that relatable Clark Kent charm and to
me the craziest example of this is the
rooftop fight when a criminal fires a
gun at Superman's place creating this
epic slow-motion bullet collision with
his eyeball which looks very cool except
come on Superman you don't even blink
like even if someone puts their finger
near your eye as a joke you still flinch
a little bit this makes Superman look
like a statue or a frozen corpse like
you could imagine him thinking okay here
comes the bullet don't move this will
look so awesome
now I should say that a moment that
makes us cringe doesn't necessarily mean
that all these movies are bad I actually
really liked a lot of the movies on this
list including another Superman movie
which has our number 12 cringe moment
from Richard Donner Superman 2
man throws the s now just to be clear
this is never one of Superman powers and
no one has any idea where this came from
it's actually rumored that it wasn't
Richard Donner who even put this in the
movie but that this was a campy Batman
TV show style
slapstick gag added by Donner's
replacement director Richard Lester okay
moving on to number 11 and sorry Hulk
fans but there's another whole cringe
moment that I just have to include don't
worry it's from the pre MCU Eric Bana
version of Hulk now I really wanted to
talk about Nick Nolte's weird overacting
but it's this moment that freaks me out
like why do we have to see the balls
eglee and it's not like this was meant
to be a Hellyeah moment it just kind of
happens and then gets brushed off it's
just very uncomfortable okay next up
number 10 electro using spider-man to
play the itsy-bitsy spider
now there were a few moments that took
me out of Andrew Garfield second
spider-man movie like Dane DeHaan gross
insane Green Goblin but the dumbest
moment was when electro smack spider-man
against the electric grid columns and
somehow the tones produce the melody of
the itsy-bitsy spider
I hate it yeah I hate this - so did
electro set this all up hours in advance
tuning each of these columns so that
they'd play the right notes moving on to
number nine the Fantastic Four now a lot
of you guys voted Reed Richards stupid
dancing in the 2005 Fantastic Four as an
honorable mention but to make this list
you got to do a lot worse than that
like the recent version of the Fantastic
Four it is in many ways the worst
superhero movie to come out in recent
years new rock stars actually did a full
breakdown of it and all the problems
with the movie and how to fix them
Hey look it's Gabe remember Gabe no I
didn't have him kidnapped so I could
start posting videos for this channel
anyway there are a lot of cringe moments
in this movie but to me the standout
example is the way the movie retconned
the things catchphrase is clobbering
time a scene shows Ben Grimm as a kid
getting abused by his older brother hey
no its clobbering time is not a phrase
you can say with a straight face when
you're about to and really take a swing
at your little brother it's just really
weird for Grimm the later embrace this
painful memory and turn it into a silly
catchphrase okay moving on to number
eight Ryan Reynolds Green Lantern movie
as a whole is just a cringy mess that
we'd all like to forget even if Ryan
Reynolds will never forget please don't
make the supersuit green or animated but
if you're somehow willing to look back
at this movie it's kind of fun to see
Ryan Reynolds floating in it in this
role considering what he ended up doing
with Deadpool later on what's harder to
watch is a talented dramatic actor like
Peter Sarsgaard giving it his all as the
villain Hector Hammond unfortunately
Hammond just comes off as over-the-top
screaming himself hoarse and pretty much
every scene
[Music]
[Applause]
that'll do peeps no one is going to
remember that okay moving on to number
seven Halle Berry as storm in x-men you
know what happens to a tone when it's
struck by lightning same thing it
happens to everything else
now when I saw this in the movie it kind
of bummed me out because in the script
this line is a funny mr. egg what
happens when a tow gets struck by
lightning it simply happens anything
else but Halle Berry has to read it as
edgy and cool same thing that happens to
anything else it just kind of sucks the
humor out of it now we shouldn't blame
Halle Berry too much this was in the
early days of superhero movies and all
the actors in this movie are really
plain things too seriously at least
Barry wasn't nearly as overdramatic as
storm was in the animated series
distress of the element come on Julie
special okay next up number six a movie
that produces no debate at all Suicide
Squad now I know opinions are still
pretty mixed on this movie somehow I had
a lot of issues with it but even as
early as the first teaser this moment
really bothered me
we're some kind of Suicide Squad come on
Will Smith you have to say the title of
the movie in the movie or is there
something in every contract that you
sign that says you have to have a line
that proves you're cooler than the rest
of the movie that's what I call a close
encounter I make this look good you know
I don't have that last one applied okay
here we are top five we're getting some
really cringey ones here so I don't know
find something to bite down on number
five the daredevil team will never
forget no no no we like that daredevil
yeah there we go and yeah like many
others I've mentioned this movie as a
whole wasn't that great of course to be
fair it was pre MCU Marvel and superhero
movies just didn't really know better in
general back then but build that is no
excuse for this weird flirty fight scene
with Matt Murdock aggressively pushing
for a date with a lecture on a
children's playground each time we could
do much from start there so are we
supposed to find Jennifer Garner beating
the crap out of a blind guy on a seesaw
while a bunch of kids cheer her on sexy
I really don't know what's going on here
have like daredevil you got cringed I
should have been saying that all along
next up number four is pretty much the
same scene but somehow way worse the
basketball scene and Catwoman now yes
the whole movie of Catwoman is just
god-awful it's literally hard to look at
the camera cuts from shot shots so fact
making everything super disorienting but
the worst example of this is the
basketball scene and warning you mica
sticks watching
[Applause]
now in case you are curious someone
counted 137 cuts in one minute and 43
seconds it's less than one shot per
second but yeah even looking past that
to sense in the acting and all the weird
sexuality look at my butt yeah look at
my abs and instead of playing real
basketball I'm just gonna hump you from
behind in front of a bunch of little
kids why are kids always cheering in the
background sorry it's not worth getting
angry okay moving on to number three
batman vs superman donna justice was one
of the most top voted and treat and for
good reason the movie makes a lot of
weird decisions there was superman
surrounded by dead people in a fiery
capital building looking merely mildly
annoyed jesse eisenberg in general
specifically the goofy Jolly Ranchers
scene and who can forget Bruce Wayne and
Wonder Woman revealing the Justice
League one of the biggest superhero
teams in all of comic-book history via
email attachment but of course these big
cringe came when Batman decided to not
kill Superman because their moms had the
same first name oh yeah okay now this
scene just didn't work the way Zack
Snyder probably expected it to I suppose
if you read into it there is some
interesting logic in Batman finally seen
Superman's humanity by realizing that he
has a mother that he's afraid to lose
just like Bruce lost his mother that
idea could work but making just the name
Martha
carry all that weight is just a shortcut
that doesn't make sense so let's move on
to number two one of the biggest
superhero movie cringes ever Rex it is
two hours and five minutes long because
it's the entire movie of Patton and
Robin Batman and Robin was so bad that
the director Joel Schumacher recently
apologized for making it every element
in this movie has become a subject of
scorn and ridicule and an example of
what not to do for every superhero movie
that came after it there are the cringy
puns from Arnold Schwarzenegger to mr.
freeze the
comfortable suit up sequences that zoom
in on butts and junk and nipples and
when you think about it the very creepy
implication that Alfred designed a super
sexy form-fitting suit for his niece but
my personal favorite is poison ivy doing
a sexy dance inside a gorilla costume um
what the hell is going on so when all of
these guys are staring up at her
transfixed by poison ivy pheromones are
they just thinking damn I guess I have a
thing for monkeys but yes the biggest
Batman and Robin cringe moment that you
guys voted comes later in this awful
scene when Batman Robin get in a bidding
war for poison ivy ending with this
ridiculous gag utility belt not a money
belt 6 million 7 million never leave
decay without it now before I get to our
number one quick honorable mention that
a lot of you guys cringed at x-men
origins specifically moments like
Wolverine getting shot in head with an
adamantium bullets to wipes his memory
which is not at all how that works and
of course the x-men origins version of
Deadpool the Merc with the mouth getting
his mouth sealed shut for some reason oh
really I didn't include these on the
list because they were less cringe
moments than I think they were just
purely bad confusing storytelling so
here we go let's get to it number 1 how
could it be anything else guys emo Peter
Parker in spider-man 3 Oh Billy now for
some reason in Sam Raimi's spider-man 3
when a venom Sindhi it attaches itself
to spider-man it doesn't just give them
an awesome black suit that we saw on the
posters it also makes them a pervy
douchebag finger guns air humping an
all-black suit and emo haircut to dance
sequences and random amazing piano
skills what now I would understand if
this behavior was presented as Peter
Parker's sad warped idea of cool and
yeah some women do roll their eyes at
Peter and he pisses off Mary Jane and
Gwen Stacy and the jazz club owner tries
to throw a mouse but that only comes
after his antics kind of win over
everyone for a second how did any of
these people at any
point thinks this guy was cool and what
kind of New York jazz band would let
this little Mike chemical romance
anywhere near the stage ha thank God
Sony plans to redo venom with a new
darker r-rated movie I feel like that's
the only way they can right this wrong
and get this awful taste out of her
mouth
I actually made another video that
explains why Sony's venom and carnage
movie might be the perfect version of
the characters that we need so
definitely go check out that video what
are your biggest cringe moments from
superhero movies how would you rank
these and did I miss any also do you
think I was too hard on any of these
movies I really want to hear from you so
let's do a giveaway a digital gift card
with a three month subscription to Verve
would you like Netflix for nerds it's
awesome I have to do is follow new
rockstars on Twitter and then post a
tweet sharing this video with the
hashtag super cringe and we will pick
five winners so get on this share this
video like it subscribe to new rock
stars for all kinds of in-depth videos
about these superhero movies and if you
really like our videos and want to be a
bigger part of what we do here you can
contribute to us on patreon at a monthly
rate that you decide big thanks to all
of our current donors especially Matthew
saw us hit me up on Twitter at ei Vox or
new rock stars on Twitter at new
rockstars to get info on a giveaway
alright thanks for watching food what
are you doing back here
want to hang out and play a robot worse
no no they are cringing at this bit
right now
it's so stupid there's only like one of
me that much
[Music]